something think something's definitely
going on he didn't sleep last night cuz
he wasn't like this yesterday this is
yeah I get a little manic when I don't
sleep I'm not manic I feel great what
are you talking about is that shirt I'm
in the pocket is that shirt made of
terry cloth mhm oh I just noticed that
too that's so cool I know I by the way I
will say Your Fashion is kind of
unmatched you're next next level kid
from stranger things fashion and I like
the mono like yellow always mono I'm
like my mom does that so I think I took
it from my mom mono mono I like looking
at like a pill or a bear a gummy bear or
something yeah I do like that your hats
always Match Your Shirt I do like the
monochromatic you always have the best
palet mustards rust sometimes do blue
sometimes I do blue and people go oh
you're doing blue mhm yeah do you have a
power color I think my power color is
mustard yeah is cuz I feel like I'm
invisible cuz I'm yellow
you we got
it I did get cuz I'm not racist and I
didn't I didn't go to Asians or yellow
so I'm really glad I didn't get that I
was like he's invisible if he go if he
goes to Subway cuz it's all yeah I was
trying to figure out where he'd be
invisible but I think there's some like
I think mosha is good at dressing M
Kevin CH is great at style oh Kevin is
next level and I'm going to throw a name
out there Nick YF Nick YF oh yeah that's
a good um Neil I think is really I like
it when people Neil yeah sometimes but
he's like I like when people go you know
what I'm going to make a conscious cuz I
remember the day he said he watched the
Jimmy iven documentary yes that was a
good one and he told me and it was Jimmy
I was like 60 and wearing a hoodie or
something or maybe older and he was like
I've decided no more hoodies like
there's an age where it's just no more
hoodies and then he started wearing
buttons down wait what is that age 50 22
i i i reject that completely I think I'm
a hoodie [__] forever but it was like
you know what it is it's don't buy a
$400 John vvos hoodie cuz you're a
hoodie guy just wear The Aviator Nation
one just wear don't make it look like a
fancy hoodie do a Han one yes I'm going
to throw a name out there right now
that's going to bother you that dresses
well dress well who Dean Del re oh Dean
dress is great every time I see de I go
where' you get that if I saw a leather
jacket on anyone else I would make fun
of them forever oh then but not he looks
great he looks great he looks great cuz
they're worn they're not wearing him
yeah yeah and they look I feel like
someone cool gave it to him or something
he pulls it off really well I think
Marin does dress you're right I was just
thinking that what I like a I like a
corduroy blazer Mark yeah yeah but I
recently saw him in shorts and he looked
great he's got a great body let's talk
about people with no fashion sense now
that's what I would like to do um let me
think um I will go
uh Rick I know Rick Rick
Ingram
where'd you go get that school shooter
or us
it's I mean where'd you get that outfit
you going to go shoot up the Gaza Strip
I mean he does not know and this because
he has no money I don't know what it is
I think like it's weird I think I was
guilty of this too I think you freeze at
the age that you become successful
whatever works remember I
had I had the backpack I had the
high-waisted Bell Bottom Jeans I had the
New Balance velcro sneak I always had
velcro sneakers cuz I always thought it
gave me more time in the day to be
successful that's how obsessed I was I'd
be like I can't waste 30 seconds day
time I Sho I get velcro a maniac and so
like I think Rick like he's like I'm
opening for Chris Rock I was wearing
this I'm Gonna Keep wearing this well he
wears a suit right when he opens for
right he just that's just like his you
know Avengers costume what I'm saying
when he gets like his other Ultra ego
the regular rig is just like you know I
mean gappy you know gappy you mean got
some Abie socks yeah Tommy Bahama but I
do Tommy Bahama you know what I mean the
fit is just it's like two sets of
pockets yeah uh yeah I I don't want
Bahama swinging back around how is abomi
weirdly enough oh did you see that
documentary in Abie did I used to work
at Abie for years that tracks they would
have put you right up front no makeup
and um no makeup you had to be very
wholesome no nail polish I work there
you did not work at you could work there
were Naish